welcome to this video playing Bernhardt
2000 from Finland so a high rated
opponent in the 15 million it Sam OS
sets a new account and his play mostly
15 minute ok so let's see what we get
him ruin I'm just playing my absolute
main line ok and early d3 huh my plane
t6o p5 I think b5 cannot really remember
and maybe this is not really why does he
take 10 seconds for Bishop b3 ok and
that this is really does not help if you
are suspicious on every move sometimes
people just need to you know light a
cigarette or get the coffee or so okay
yes on a4 before is nowadays almost
universally considered to be the right
reaction how do hi
mr. Shyam yaya shaffer Alice milk tada
she didn't meet Jo I scler your [ __ ]
done me too yeah okay I need to switch
off the audio for a second because I got
a phone call that I needed to need it to
take ok so I'm nothing nothing much
happened really Knight to c4 mmm Jenna I
guess I should take it trading off the
offside night should be something and I
also like to play this move I don't like
like it if white manages to play a five
so we have a position pretty typical of
the room maneuvering type of position
might take and pawn pawn recaptures TM
bokkeum bishop e6 is probably not great
how to play here
we should be 60 can take queen bee three
it's not great Bishop g4 is normally
pointless with with the porn on d3 as I
don't have any pressure on the phone hmm
of course i'd like to get to get this
Bishop exchanged this would be would be
helpful but yeah Bishop a6 he's just
going to retreat yeah I have some ideas
to to get it to trade it but it's not
really great he will play deform
okay I haven't entirely different that
yeah let's see if I can manage that the
idea sir to play 97 b6 Bishop f6 and
then d5 tried to break in the center
myself the bishop on b7 is at the moment
just staring at this pawn but at least
it's making it more difficult for white
to play deform yes that's one of this
that is one move that I had expected I
just thot 97 would be it would be good
in an exchange certainly is ok for me I
guess when he 72 certainly the less
active bishop compared to his possible
posts on e3 on forever and as I'm
somewhat somewhat worse at the center I
don't think exchanges hurt me too much
yes this is why i was thinking i was a
bit worse in the center he gets this in
and okay
Knight to f6 backhand probably put
pressure on your form should be okay now
this Knight b6 ideas it's nonsense I
mean I never got to play d5 here so the
knight on f6 should put some pressure on
only form here what should ido maybe
should be three simply retreating okay
but if he goes Bishop d3 yes I can
probably just capture and play Roxy it
shouldn't be you shouldn't be bad for
black just here and Roxy eight dance
looks fairly fairly solid ready
I'm on the sea foam so if you play
something like Roxy one I can exchange
mailbox yet I cannot really do much in
terms of activity I think simply due to
the fact that there's always some
pressure on e5 the knight on f3 and the
foreman defaults always putting some
pressure on only five but you cannot
really um cannot really increase that
much yes this is real always possible
just closing it I was thinking 97 to see
500 him yeah and I'm doing for that
right away if you go with some yeah I
just put it down it shouldn't be bad
really maybe I have some some ways to to
improve after that night to see 50 no no
this is this is fine I can try to play
for f5 of course strategically speaking
um I have the better Bishop now with the
pawns on dark squares Queenie to assign
curious month not really I didn't expect
that at all okay I want to prepare five
anyway
I thought you would play Bishop see two
anyway the night on c5 is really a good
piece it's am putting pressure on e4 and
a 4d for was a positional error I think
yeah this is this is better for black
somewhat more comfortable I came prolab
maybe night I will not see for I can
take Bishop a six okay that's not that's
not great really okay can i play a five
or is this is this too early they are
not see 494 is putting some pressure on
this I bishop at Bishop a 6 is also
playable and good in fact okay so let me
just prepare prepare a 5 with some moves
yes did I was hoping that he's doing
that because I push up a six but he gets
PS night takes in five year ah he's got
a knight takes d5 thats thats that
stupid
okay i can also you can also try night
be three to deform also interesting
i take c 5 this is to desire yeah okay I
was really trying to tempt him into 94
might take C fibers of course really
really annoying okay should I put it on
d4 it's not clear that it's better on d4
then it is on and then it is on c5 9 p-3
look somewhere 94 can it's not a bad
square now to deform okay
a5 is hanging yes that's just protected
and see if I can improve yes
yeah probably yeah this oversight wasn't
helping this letter that i missed bishop
a6 really really not good and this is a
constant problem if I co bishop a six
now it's again night XD five
hmm
don't really see a good continuation
Jan I'm getting the night to d4 was
probably not good yeah i was i was a bit
i was a bit in doubt anyway about this
anted truth to be not so great yeah well
for technical reasons we Swiss Miss
withdrawing the night that that's
interesting
hmm
okay night niger nigeria on the agenda
but if i go Queen to d7 and I'm covering
that and i'ma taking a form a form might
be unimportant might be
yeah if i take it Nyjah form
94 but not f6 is not a direct threat
because of the d1 look hanging you know
it's still it's still dangerous without
without question it's dangerous but in
general an eye chief is is really doing
much maybe all night for just win g7 and
then preparing Bishop c8 a Quincy five
maybe ok anyway I don't I'm more afraid
of this night if it is on the queenside
then it is on the Kings side maybe this
is the wrong judgment but I him he can
he can get in the knight to f6 to f6 of
all places ok
but this is also a liability and I'd
have six kinking away and then I'm
threatening h2h six and g5 winning the
night not sure that this is a good plan
it may be but oh we can play night age
six a night f7 check ah that's winning
check that's winning I only thought
about this one yeah yeah that's a shame
really after night c5 we had an
absolutely dream position it was a
really substantial already but I miss
plated lie to d4 was was not good at all
not at all check
yeah the ruler passes a very difficult
opening he can just take the six I mean
that many moves winning but 26 is the
easiest black resigns yeah that's um
that's really lost that hurts a bit
because so in this position whitis is
essentially already already out plate
but I didn't play it right really this
this night transfer was a bad idea
really a bad idea yeah maybe I've just
played it too slowly and when the
computer already wants to go here and
claim some baguettes yeah which is which
is certainly okay I didn't wanted to
make this this kind of this kind of
direct play but this is obviously good
for black getting this pawn and probably
this or this as well and this will be
much better than the night yeah but I
wanted to play it slowly prepare it the
old out the whole problem was that I was
relying on this move and there's 95 but
maybe I should have should have thought
about this a bit longer this was my
original idea and this might still be
okay and then Roxy hive this is
fantastic for blood oh no
yeah it was clear that that I had missed
something but this is really easy look
at this distance this is completely
completely crushing he cannot get out of
the spin something like this is a
disaster he must be must play a move
like b3 at some point and then I can't
even take him that's funny because of
this tactic check yeah white white was
already in big trouble this was a
mistake yeah I mean it was a mistake in
various ways it didn't help getting the
night to d4 and had this night XD 3
which is almost winning wow yeah yes
absolutely no no way to play him I mean
this kind of position is just a disaster
I have the protected passer and dismiss
this target on c4 care and this is I
mean this is not yet Blair not yet bet
for black but i really i really am had
misplayed it he has got f form and the
knight on d4 it looks pretty but it
doesn't too much of course I don't need
to lose some in the way I did in the
game but but it's not it's not easy
anymore to play Knight B 3 i'm supposed
to be good again i'm not sure why
because of the check or what exactly is
the defense just we just getting it back
okay yeah maybe computer gives me a big
advantage she as well but I'm not so
sure about that but this is this is not
working really yeah Queen g seven
assists a bad mistake creed ii 7 is
still good for black because i get in
yeah it's all about tactics as usual I
was I was I was relying on night FC i
forgot about night h6 this is just
blundering it away completely we call
still gives this this is equal which I
find quite quite amazing yeah maybe yes
he has a terrible bishop and so on if we
get if we exchange the heavy pieces I'm
winning this easily against the stead
bishop okay overlook night h6 simply I
when I was already very frustrated a bit
because because I noticed that I had to
had spoiled it in a way but it wasn't so
bad really it wasn't so bad Queenie 7 is
much better as well night getting the
nitrogen for this is really anti
positional it was excellent on c4 I get
it to g4 I mean he got it to g4 because
of this this trick which I run into like
a baby but that's of course not
necessary if i manage bishop see ATM i'm
in good shape
maybe he needs to do this and now not
sure 57 I don't know this is at least a
game I didn't they don't need to lose so
quickly about about it still it was a an
interesting game thanks for watching